what's my name Terry Jeffords what is my
name the ebony Falcon and what does the
ebony Falcon do takes every precaution
to ensure his own safety takes bad guys
to jail and bad girls to bed hey yay
Sep now that evany Falcon is monogamous
and too tired for sex so it's only
indulgence it's fresh fruit yogurt
parfaits Terry loves yogurt what's that
smell that's lavender Terry loves
lavender a little homemade honey yogurt
infused with lavender and love hold it
this isn't some weird breast milk or
something as a board I mean technically
it's from a sheep's breast sir my life
stinks Sharon's on bed rest
my favorite mango yogurt got
discontinued and my kids think their
preschool teachers a stupid-face why is
there yogurt on this the Deputy
Commissioner through my report and
Terry's trash can and he'd been eating
yogurt earlier Terry loves yogurt
Francois Truffaut's breathless what
Terry likes porn films I need somebody
followed a lineup will you be scary
Terry scary Terry he says what braking
uh Terry's thinking can I be honest
precincts not the same without the
vultures the worst my mango yogurt Yeti
mentioned it's important I hate how hard
it is to guess other people's passwords
wait everyone wait try yogurt would ya
Oh Terry loves yogurt look Terry loves
love but Terry also loves maintaining a
professional work environment you find
something you care about it's taken from
you your colleague the dream job your
mango yogurt whatever Gary he gave me
the hard sell look at all
swag I got a puppy best carabiner
Terry carabiners suck you want free
stuff there you go all right you can
have anything you want from Amy's desk
Gary made me an offer better hours great
benefits a serious pay raise my old
office with walls did you tell him Terry
doesn't love walls no Terry loves walls
now they're destroying our technology
this is an invasion they're in my yogurt
now it's personal okay fine
just one mm-hmm damn these are good plus
your organic and fair trade Terry loves
responsible agricultural practices
damn it Boyle you left the fridge open
the door couldn't shut because of your
empty pizza box
it's heats up please this is a butternut
squash and truffle butter flatbread
everything spoiled my lunch is ruined
chicken potatoes pasta meatballs
yogurt yogurt I love yogurt so this is
your lunch for like the mud I need to
eat 10,000 calories a day to maintain
muscle mass my wife made me all of this
before she left town with the kids that
was everything in my fridge Scully
hey Sarge I know you got a secret stash
food hidden somewhere oh no where is it
no I don't is it here pocket come on I'm
gonna shake it out of your pockets
turn around Sarge Scully
oh this is fun I can't believe they all
let CJ and Gina just buy them off we
don't need them cuz we've got you and
you're a sergeant
she's signed a letter yet what did he
give you he gave me the ability to
continue to serve this community
unencumbered by a necessary oversight
now I really have where did he give you
he gave me a yogurt fridge all right
where is it I got one right next to my
desk I'm only a man I'm sending this
letter with or without your signature
enjoy your blood yoghurt congratulations
you just made sure that a terrible
captain will be sticking around here
indefinitely
come on Santiago we're just trying to
make the best of it
yo never and if I made you the third
toast
it'll be focused primarily on the mango
yoke something important to chew she
cheat on earth no I would never do that
did you date one of her friends right
after you broke up uh uh
I could off ties with all our mutual
friends even Tommy
Terry love Tommy Tommy turned Terry on
the tennis I can't believe they call
this a silent disco this is not a disco
and I should know I was raised on disco
little Terry loved the hustle let me get
that for you
I can do it tiny Terry loves pickles
Paul seems bad Jake why aren't you more
upset because Sofia's problem isn't with
me it's with her dumb boss that's
something I can fix I'm gonna make him
like me
here is the target geoffrey hoytsman now
according to the internet his interests
are skiing his Terrier Atlantic City the
film 12 years of slave and nature
obviously nature is super boring and the
slave film is a little bit dicey it's
real dicey yeah so I will focus mainly
on skiing and Atlantic City when I
talked to him tonight at the fundraiser
for the association of Brooklyn Public
Defenders aka the chamber of asses
oh wait that's too sexy the chamber of
snakes anyway it starts at 8:00 so you
should probably get dressed what I am
NOT going to that please Sarge just come
do it for me do it for love damn Jake
you know Terry loves love I mean all
right now put on your phoniest smile cuz
we're going into the belly of the beast
phonier phonier
you